hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to simulacra 2. this is
maya look at maya look at maya's eyes
look at maya's lips look at my's nose
look at my hair the flowers something
ain't right about maya
unless this is a perfectly normal
picture of mine then i'm very sorry but
something don't seem right about maya i
need to know what the greatest gift to
maya's life is and i'm not gonna answer
dr matilo's
whatever your name is i'm not gonna
answer their inquisition until
i'm able to did i do this
i already did this
yep i did that so there's gotta be
something that says what the greatest
thing
what was it again greatest gift to you
okay greatest gift to you this sounds
like a chimera thing a chimera thing
namaste you guys good morning
everything to do in the morning first
thing
and this natural idea is great for you
powerful i hope that you guys can adopt
this as your daily practice
and while you're there take three deep
breaths for yourself right i like to
keep it really simple
i'll just inhale love and exhale ego
three times and then i get on with my
day and it's always amazing
i see nothing about the greatest thing
ever in your life forever
but there might be something so proud of
my gals and mind body fitness
people always think that my life's
perfect but that's just so far from the
truth who thinks that struggled with my
health for the longest time okay i had
no energy to get out of bed i was losing
hair and i was just in so much pain
so what i did was i went to study
nutrition to learn what works for me
because
doctors they don't even know that much
anyway they're just trying to sell you a
big pharma you just gotta go listen to
what your heart tells you
what style by arya there's kind of what
is
what is the greatest gift what is your
greatest gift to you
okay
all right who are these people wait oh
right
the phone is acting weird her inner
circle of friends
good
you read their statements then if you
didn't recall detective murillo is
asking what is wrong with detective
morillo's face
we found their prince all over maya's
apartment but that just means they were
over a lot so our guys didn't bother
questioning them much idiots find
anything new about them they all work
together
i said anything new
we already know they all influence her
whatnot on social media did they say
anything about maya
mai was acting weird before she died
that's pretty obvious from the videos
she left behind what do you think
they're hiding something
seems like we're on the same page
change of tactics
we need to attack from multiple angles i
need you to talk to them individually
why the change of tactics
if they're lying it's easier to cover
for each other as a group but if you
separate them they might crack classic
prisoners dilemma that's a good point
find out who they really are and what
their connection to maya is on a
professional and
personal level they'll talk if they see
maya's corpse
i guess
god no
dial it way down warm them up a bit make
it conversational try getting their
alibis for the night by a die too
keep an eye out for any slip ups if they
have let their guard down they might
accidentally reveal a bit too much
um camera what what was that
what
excuse me
sorry that wasn't for you
interesting
offline eight detective marilla were you
trying to activate my camera okay so
what's this
wow lost a friend recently knowing her
she wouldn't want me moving around you
admire dedicating my next million earned
to you
all right well that's nice
video
setting up the damn
camera
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what why
why was there an alarm
you uh you are buddy need help with your
camera
shut up and get back to work this
influencer life really is something
[Music]
you've been learning more about our
victims feels wrong looking some uh
yeah i read the case file already
i said more
like i said
hello
to understand the crime we have to
really know the victim down to every
last detail
looks like she had some stalkers
stalker eh maybe one got a bit too
obsessive
look i know i'm pushing you here
but even seemingly insignificant scraps
of information might just tell something
about this case just keep looking you'll
see i'm right
okay thanks moles i'm gonna go
talk to
great video i'm gonna go talk to people
ah
interesting we need to talk alone i've
got more questions that's a bit that's a
bit much that's a bit strong
i've got more questions do i need a
lawyer for this conversation do you have
one
i have a family one
but i'm not worried because i'm innocent
can we please just get this over with so
i can get back to my life
see
anything i can do to make this easier
short of leaving me alone
you start by getting to the point
everything is falling apart and i have
to pretend everything is fine work has
been stressful enough as it is
okay
what's falling apart my entire career by
the looks of it
mike admire account is going down and
i'm not sure why
as devastated as i am right now i still
have to craft the perfect rip response
for my followers otherwise my
performance will tank even further
interesting this job feels quite
demanding
i know a thing or two about the stresses
of influencement it's a ruthless
industry so i need to stay competitive
it's not really though your followers
can make or break you in innocent
don't give them that power you have to
keep them happy at all times
i find mocking them works a lot better
and that means making sacrifices okay i
do agree with that i do make a lot of
goat sacrifices i don't kill them or
anything
but i am sacrificing
them for them with them on them around
them
you fill in the gaps
see sounds like they own you
it's a two-way relationship it's not
it's parasocial they live their lives
vicariously through me i get to live my
life as i please
[Laughter]
work doesn't feel like a job so most of
us pressured worth it
were you working the night
do you think the pressure got to maya
[Music]
seems like she was never good at
handling stress he was always over doing
it
with her lifestyle who knows what kind
of supplements she was popping
maybe she dropped dead in her living
room from pure exhaustion how do you
know where she died
i'm just putting the pieces together
okay isn't that your job
are you done because i am i'd like to
get back to my shoot i'll leave it to
you then
farewell
glad to be of help oh
you're welcome
all right
rex
what is this maya
are you just going to keep ignoring me
just be straight up you don't have to
hide from me i'm not going to bite
if you can't handle the pressure or this
thing's really not working out let's
just hash it out like adults
i remember that i've got more questions
god why you got to use maya's number
almost killed me there i get it
hilarious man this is why cop's got a
bad rep humorless
anyway mr officer time is money
so shoot those questions uh maya was
your business partner
yeah with the other two
just four independent adults looking to
escalate their portfolios to the next
level gotta rethink my workflow now that
maya's gone figure out a new career plan
problems keep piling up on me see sounds
like maya's death really affected you
yeah i counted on her a lot it's a big
loss
monetarily speaking
pros like me are used to pushing through
our personal [ __ ] to make our
enterprises work
so quit the small talk what do you
really want from me no i want anyone who
might armor
uh she was so boring no way she had any
enemies so my theory
maya went on some [ __ ] detox
self-care trip whatever she did there
messed up her face
oh
how do you know about her face injuries
uh wild guess
my theory tends to accidentally
on point i'm a visionary
[Laughter]
i've got you [ __ ] let's see uh how is
that
well for one image is everything
and death's a bummer for any brand
okay time's up you need anything else
i could have made 7 800 bucks in these
few minutes i'm talking to you
we'll be in touch
wrap it up fast will you
oh i will
i've got more questions
mind trouble detective
i just want to hear your side of the
story
i mean
i don't know what else to say
i can't help thinking like i could have
helped her somehow
it's so sad that she died alone she was
a close friend
she was my manager but we were friends
too
she believed in me from the start you
know i was struggling to get anyone to
listen to me but she heard me
she helped me change my look and made me
who i am today sounds like you owe a lot
to her
all of us do
she taught me a lot about this business
follower numbers matter more than talent
even maya got worried when she lost
followers all that stress must have even
her up inside did she show signs of
stress before this
just recently before she
i should have been there for her more
i keep thinking about how she died
like what if no one reported her death
if that random person didn't call the
cops would anyone have found her
how do you know about the anonymous
caller
um
heard the cops talking about it
[Laughter]
[Music]
interesting all this my talk is really
triggering me right now i need some
alone time
we will get to the bottom of this
oh we'll get to the bottom of this all
right
have you guys got tickets to my show yet
i promise it's been worth it been
practicing non-stop
interesting no it isn't easy this life
isn't for everyone so before you think
you can do my job let me spare you some
wisdom don't compare yourself to me ever
you're not on my level and you never
will be
wow
all right okay
oh boy
you guys
thank you so much for coming out to my
show tonight
i really felt the love
sometimes the pain is so raw
i can't even find the words
maya
mine was my guiding light
without her i'm just
groping around in darkness you know
[Music]
it's like that just stalks me everywhere
i go like i have to keep crashing into
tides of
suffering
for you guys
[Music]
tonight
it was just me pouring myself into the
music
and i know that's what she would have
wanted
[Music]
beautiful i think feel like a moth
flying wild and blind rest in peace maya
your light's always in my heart
i
ha i see uh my is flying very peacefully
and something or other or something like
that so i've got some contradictions
time to report my findings
i spoke to them individually
learn anything new
something they said bothered me
this sounds promising
what do you have
they knew details of the crime scene
what
all we told the public is maya died of
unknown causes nothing else what did
they tell you
arya mentioned malaya dying in the
living room
you'd have to be at the crime scene to
know that or make a very lucky guess
uncovered any other info meena knew
about the anonymous caller
aside from the department only the
emergency dispatcher would know about
this or the caller themselves okay what
else rex says something about a face
being injured
only we know about those marks
either information leaked or you know
something we don't is that everything
you have
what's your take they could have been
there
they could have been there it's possible
but if they're lying we have to prove it
what else can we pursue they all told me
similar stories
similar eh what's the pattern they can't
stop talking about their work
can't they put their lives on hold for
just one second damn kids in there
so what's your opinion
her death might be tied to their jobs
maya just died and all they want to do
is work
i see why you think it's connected but
it's a hunch at best we need more proof
what do you think
i think their lying is what it is
i just don't know to what extent
they're intentionally withholding
information
i believe so too
they must have seen or heard something
whatever happened to maya spooked them
enough to stay mum they must be
conspiring
right
they shouldn't be keeping things from us
we need solid evidence to nail them
i tried getting your laptop myself with
this chief switch the locks to the
evidence room if you don't find a way to
access maya's laptop remotely the trail
ends here all right well i know how to
do that i know how to do that i know
just how to do that not that one god
damn it
whoa
tired of losers holding back your
perfect self always
sick of trolls being hit on your pursuit
image my god they're doing it right now
are your loyal admirers turning into
persistent haters every single day of my
life they keep betraying me you
ever wish you could reshape your current
reality yes yes yes take these questions
to see how you'd like your reality to be
shaped into which image just best
describes how you see yourself i see
myself ominously floating up in the
middle of the woods yes yes that's what
i've always assumed of myself
what do you see your journey to the top
feel like
i see my journey to the top being an
explosion of pink absolutely that's my
journey to the top that's everyone's
journey to the top baby what do you seek
the most i seek an ever-ending spiral of
unimaginable chaos
that's pink
what would you change about yourself
i would definitely change the fragmented
mirror of realities that reflects the
border between universes
what am i willing to become
oh i'm willing to become a crowd of
faceless masks people
uh lixie and censor that last one
hey hey what
your confidence drives you
and rivals wither your path what holds
you back is the weakness of others and
self-doubt improve your content and
ambition by being quick decisive and
head of the curve no matter what it
takes you got it i'm about to be ahead
of the curve
what
discovered missing group chapter but
wait wait
can i diva it up
could i diva myself
fine
fine
group chat tied to a video sync to
maya's laptop ah
i need to get into that laptop baby
i like the power people fearing me i
used to be a huge bully maybe i am well
i sure lived my tragic story i was just
lonely
hmm
need a boost reveal the identity of the
introducer introducer someone introduced
maya to an influencer boosting service
huh
interesting so there was
an influencer boosting service
somewhere
but where
but whoa
hi
group chat okay i need to get into the
laptop unless this is
this one
but i don't think it is
no no no okay so i gotta get into the
laptop and to do that i've got to do
something
god damn it really it was ah i didn't
even see this all my fans of my
followers are the greatest gift
the greatest gift is fans
that is the greatest gift
favorite song
[Music]
delir multi-colored lies multicolored
lies
what quote do you rate it to the most uh
my god look at her fat fat ass
oops okay
so this also has to be either a jabber
quote or uh a chimera
aim high new beginnings it's gotta be
new beginnings new beginnings ah that's
it
[Music]
baby
oh boy what is this eyebrow wait a
minute
wait a minute
wait a minute what's this what this what
is this i see
stop it
otherwise we're all going to die please
please just use me
i mean like why why would a boosting
service want to kill us because the
ripple listen okay the ripple man is not
real maya you have to stop it the
service is a bit weird yes but it's
probably just a marketing ploy and a
prank to mess with our heads a prank
our following shot right through the
roof after we signed up that's not
normal come on it's just an algorithmic
hack it doesn't run on magic
this thing wants me as a sacrifice
because if we don't stop it this is not
gonna end with me
what's this ripple man gonna do wave us
to death if i show it to you on my phone
will you believe me
this one
all of this
can be explained babe
you're just stressed out okay
it's okay it's okay you're just stressed
out i'm not throwing away my future
because you're going nuts
i'm trying to save us all of us
maybe if we use the different service or
something instrumentally that might help
we lay for that now this is already
happening but we can stop it okay this
is all just because of that stupid deal
right
okay look no one's gonna take that deal
so nothing's gonna happen
you know i'm not stupid to go for some
vague trade
hey
hey are you okay
hey don't look at me
oh
[Music]
oh no she's glitching
she's glitching right the [ __ ] out
the ripple man she died suddenly shortly
after
i thought she would die like a bit more
explosively and like being levitated in
the air and then blood being shot out of
her wounds all of it sucked out right
through her face wounds
um but that was also death
um
okay
there's
what this might be surprising but i'm
not
i'm at the mercy of a fickle algorithm
and fleeting interest this might be
certain but i'm not happy with my life i
definitely feel lucky and grateful for
what i have but it's not without hard
work and sacrifice my influence is not
next and control is what i crave the
most yet the longer i'm in this field
the more powerless i feel this platform
is unpredictable i'm at the mercy of a
fickle algorithm and fleeting interest
it's a battle i'm slowly losing or
though i thought i found this through
the ads and it changed the tide for me
trm gave me a level control i didn't
know it's possible i'm at the birthday
of a fickle algorithm and fleeting
interest what this is why schedule posts
are such a bad idea
okay well this is strange um but now i
definitely have
this group chat from this lappy toppy
what is this i have a question about the
boosting thingy have you seen your new
card the one with the weird messaging
you mean this thing
who
you relish your position as a star among
people around you playing it out as my
own perceived role as much as possible
in an ever increasing grandeur
where you are the hero in a never-ending
story
you move people with your
larger-than-life persona and sweep
others away with your performance and
influence yes i do embrace your
influence and grow your prestige this
deal requires the sacrifice
um
well guys
start sacrificing i need to have my
influence and my prestige grow big and
strong become engorged if you will
so uh
chop chop with the likes and subscribes
and shares and the whatnot actor i
didn't even read that
i didn't i didn't even read that i just
read this and it was very ah that that
[Music]
oh wow um
interesting
not sure what this was that red and blue
did i uh
[ __ ]
yeah that one i don't think it seems
very off it's just some dumb
personality-based upselling tactic they
try and psych you out to buy their stuff
but what does it mean by a deal for a
personal sacrifice i feel like trm wants
to trap us somehow what is it asking for
a sacrifice
maybe i should ask florence she was
using drm before
florence you say but i just think about
the timing of it we're all facing so
much hate from our followers right and
suddenly now we get the so-called offer
to get rid of all that and the car
describes it's like it knows our brands
like it knows us i got the musician one
so is it stealing our data or something
is it watching us i'm just worried okay
ah okay okay okay look it's just like a
tracking metrics all right so it scans
my profile and sees my mad moolah skills
and bam i get the tycoon card kinda
kooky but i gotta say it's pretty
impressive and tempting oh my god i know
right i just can't with all these people
just tearing me down i got more hate
mail today people telling me to kill
myself and stuff so you think this
service thing will make it all go away
haters man they're always waiting to
claw you anyway this add-on sounds kind
of [ __ ] though just gonna ignore it
i think it's a good idea as long as
we're on the same page this is urgent i
need to explain in person i'm not sure
that i understand it myself but just
come over to my place tonight
i need you to be here please
it's really important
how did you send this back in time how
did you send this like earlier in time
and so worried about you like i was
getting sick thinking something might
have i figured it out here in the cards
my ass are friends of me at her
department the day before she died
interesting you're scaring me what have
you been smoking
rex stop being so freaking rude
okay my babe you
you gotta stop having a rack attack okay
let's just all meet up and sort this out
in person
none of you are capable of writing
that's obvious
okay weird interesting later gators huh
okay so i can text more in the group
chat that's that's obvious
i don't think i reveal the identity of
oh wait florence flory
someone before yeah
florian
florence
i'm opening it maya florence i was
wondering if you got this no big e
chemericon vouchers ask 20k
to 100k in two weeks just like
different surprise you don't know about
it ads on chimera have a trm tailored
reputation management buying likes god
never sink that low
you're in a pod right get your friends
to do it as well
that's emily of x well that's probably
important x-u-x-i-u-l-i-n
emily okay oh my god florence i tried
and it works
it's so weird it totally works florence
you there lauren something's wrong we
all get a huge follower boost and the
numbers are going up but the dislike
ratio is getting worse and now there's
some kind of deal i'm not sure maya
worked out well i see not quite i just
want to ask did you take this deal it
offered you the deal is quite remarkable
no it allows you to control your fate i
just took i took it it worked out
completely just embrace everything it
offers you right uh
i think if florence might be dead pretty
sure richard florence might be dead
i don't think i have the ability to find
that particular person's things okay um
well actually i'm going to go to the
chat i want to talk to these guys first
hey later guys what do you know about
this trm
what do you know about this drm
who which trm what do you know about
this actor type what is this all about
whoa
how the heck do you get old messages
from a wiped phone rex they don't know
what we know the phone is wiped
it was ari's idea to wipe it clean well
interesting and meena just watched how
dare you we all agreed to this
hmm there's no point hiding anymore so
let's just be on front what are you
trying so hard to hide
trm
whoa
come on guys the boosting service my
introduces to she says he was being
haunted by it she said it stood for
tailored reputation management
then she called it the ripple man for
some reason
she brought it up as a solution for our
ratings dropping interesting interesting
i guess some people would sell their
soul to keep their internet fame i would
never do that cranking up the blame
train already huh you know statistically
the accuser is always guilty right
whoa
why did i get no chance for that
so since ari why did i get zero time for
that
oh applying those statistics to yourself
now accuser
uh guys how can a boosting service kill
someone
the ripple man offered a deal for a
great sacrifice so someone must have
taken the deal and sacrificed maya
someone for all we know you're the one
who took it does the act of innocence
come with a side of lies i didn't take
it
was that why maya was so distressed
yes and no
the deal was can supposedly wipe out any
bad publicity from our chimera pages
even when maya was getting flack
if you didn't pressure so much he might
not have gone to such extreme
you guys got to learn to deal with
things in a healthy way a deal that
kills people
i didn't know that's what it meant
we got a quote ahead to hit okay
you got to be trending 24 7 or you lose
everything unfortunate but true
this sounds like people that have never
trended 24 7 ever are you saying you
took the deal hey we all agreed to the
service and i never took the deal what
in the world did you get to yourself
what in the world do you get yourselves
into
what the hell is this i don't know what
else to say okay this whole thing is
totally bizarre you were at the crime
scene
maya recorded us you lied to the police
i wanted to call the cops
but arya said no one would believe us
thanks mina for throwing me under the
bus yeah nice snitching meena
you wanted to run away too okay time out
here put yourself in our shoes
who's gonna believe us if if we said
that some face tearing monster killed
her let's see i'm listening
now
i'm here i'm listening all right okay
fine not like we're going anywhere
thanks mister let's skip down
i don't even know where to start
it all happened so fast face explosion
disease just happens she was fine like
oh my god can you guys take turns to
speak
i thought i was hallucinating or
something
and bam she just she just
it was like it was invisible at first
her face burst open
what's this ripple man maya spoke about
oh um i'm like not sure
just something maya named whatever the
hell that was that was all right who
knows why yes poor thing must have said
it in fear it was terrifying for all of
us
i told you think of how bad it was for
us we had to watch our friend get their
face exploded you ever seen someone you
kind of work with and also respect maybe
kind of use for influentials
there have their face explode
you ever have to witness that no
we only lied about maya being nuts
before she kicked the blanket the
blockade let's see so who
who took the ripple man's
deal
100 i'd never screw maya over so that's
50 50 between these two oh my god you
liar
why don't i start with you rex
oh boy oh
boy can we just get on a group call do
you guys have discord can we make this
easy what's the deal here real
frustrating oh my god
meanest [ __ ] boohoo stories
backfiring in her face what area's like
a total sell oh my god
guys
get rich quick i know well actually wow
man i just wanted to pick one
guys
guys
guys
let's take this one step at a time
why don't we do that
nope
great i'm done with this [ __ ]
oh my god you guys are the worst
it's not like you have anything on me
right anyway right i'm done here
wait a minute yeah you got nothing on us
why the hell am i wasting time on any of
you they're so rude
um so you can't do anything to us i can
try to help you if you want to speak in
private that's what i thought found
anything yet rookie
you better not be slacking off why would
i be slacking off
what would you even think that i'd be
doing to slack off how could i even
slack off
i'm slacking
i'm about to slack off
oh
that's not good
i'm fixing it
oh
i'm pov now
new bikinis
new beginnings
new beginnings
so what about that
okay good i'm glad that i was able to
see inside someone's soul for a few
moments that was lovely
i found stuff
[Music]
another thing if you're going to keep
putting your nose all over my business
and accuse me of all sorts of [ __ ] i am
going to sue you for defamation and
harassment
don't make me get my claws out all right
oh no rex keegan's claws are coming out
guys guys
rex keegan's about to uncle
i'd appreciate a response right now one
of our suspects just threatened me
huh well get used to it it means we're
on the right track
enough screwing around get back to it
focus on getting more intel have you
heard of this trm
you're gonna get the diva card
no it looks like another piece to the
puzzle
what
isn't that the ad on chimera that keeps
popping up about that boosting service
so as the servers factor in
it offered this is related to maya's
death
somehow what happened
item is not accounted for all handling
officers in the police report to the
chief's office for immediate debriefing
dig through the phone there has to be
something in there that proves i'm right
oh
there's something alright look at this
take a look at one of these
take a look at this even though i told
you that they were already there you're
offline why are you offline detective
murillo
[Music]
how about you saw the video yeah this
ripple man i thought it was just an
urban legend like that jeff the killer
story but but this is proof
they call me crazy i'll show them who's
crazy i'll i
i have to go too many years here you
tell them who's crazy ah something just
went in my eye and no damn respect
can't even get privacy in my own damned
office i should have been a pianist but
no
i had to serve and protect
okay detective marillo
you have a lovely day now well i'll be
damned
video evidence looks like she had a
seizure of some sort and these kids
stood there watching it they lied to my
face what the hell is happening there
i have a theory
but i need more proof
the ripple man a deal we need them to
really spill the beans
i showed this to them
nice work
their stories are starting to crack we
have some leverage now
we need to figure out who this ripple
man is who this pee-pee poo-poo man
really is and the deal and this deal
they keep talking about we're close a
little more digging we'll get to the
bottom of this no time this is worse
than i thought we are dealing with a
simulacrum what what
i'm familiar with those i'm familiar
with those you're definitely fit for
this department kid
dupe really has a place for you and his
heart no one knows what these creatures
are but they all use online
communication as a cover lurking behind
websites social media apps i don't know
what they want but they sure love
screwing with us
so there are more of these
the body count they're leaving behind is
rising too
see what is the one with us
from my experience with the previous
ones
it wants to possess humans
this one is a hell of a long con
it baits its victims by promising fame
on chimera knowing that they will
eventually slip up under the glare of
the limelight then it offers them a deal
to remove all criticism for a price
that's a pretty good deal that's a
pretty good deal
i don't get it what's so great about
some internet likes
you don't know
the rush is better than drugs it's
better than anything it's better than
sex
imagine if you got a like in the middle
of sex wow
anyway maybe they didn't realize that
maya was the cost
i have my doubts
one of them must have known these
selfish idiot kids one of them unleashed
the ripple man
this thing will claim more victims if we
don't stop it
we need to find out who did it
and then end the pee-pee poo-poo man
it's gonna be tough but here's my idea
this deal removes criticism and
brickbats right what the frick is a
brick bat but i'm sure these kids did
something to spark that backlash if we
can find out what they did and why
maybe we can figure out who did the deal
hmm how do we find evidence of this i
already know go through their social
medias
the good thing about the doodle is
start going through their social media
it's impossible to attract so much bad
juju without doing something bad figure
out what it is and confront them with it
whoever took the deal must have a lot to
lose
precisely
they would do anything to defend what
they've got you're handling this solo
for now i need to settle some things
i'll talk to them one by one
not before doing some digging first
start with whoever you want but don't
talk to them without proof
we're looking for any evidence of them
mucking up so bad that they are begging
for a chance to wipe away
all that negativity
discovered a deleted email you said
oh okay
hi another thing yeah watch your back
watch your back i don't like this seeing
visions one bit i didn't tell you rabbit
hole is definitely not gonna end up in
wonderland
i literally did not tell you about that
i quite literally did
not
say
anything about that all right let's go
through their social modules
let's face it exercising sucks
hmm let's go on an adventure where would
you take me i don't know a few minutes
later a bird pooped on my head i'm sure
haha yes
oh [ __ ]
no
[Music]
hi chicas
okay it's really hard for me to do this
i want to apologize for the allurin
thing
you know sometimes
you edit hundreds of photographs and
videos and the wrong one gets uploaded
and
you know that was just
that was just a rehearsal you know it's
me messing around
and it's
it's just not fair that
one mistake
was just one mistake and it brought so
much hate
sorry
i was bullied so much growing
and up now feels like it's happening all
over again
[Applause]
and to be torn down by your own
community when you're already giving it
your all
everything i know is for you
hey
he
we didn't have to was this just a
rehearsal you didn't have to
post this one
okay so i remember seeing something
about this with like
okay not this one
[Music]
i'm not naming these because they don't
particularly wannabes are doing the they
just want fame talking to you babs baby
doll
okay there's gotta be something else
here uh inner bombshell gorgeous no
matter what love yourself okay
ah here we go
i saw this one super exciting news
guess who's the latest alluring
uh-huh
but unfortunately
some of the videos wrong
obviously lying okay so lying about
getting a brand deal which honestly
is fascinating discrepancies in the
announcement okay got that i already i
already saw this before
turns out that i didn't need to go
through all these uh beforehand because
i would have found them anyway okay so
there's something here
in minas
ah here we go
aha well is it a personal tragedy has
been a major source of inspiration but
some of our fans are doubting this
interesting there's probably only one
piece of info per oh wait more
mina enjoys wallowing in self-pity and
uses it as a means to get attention from
others all right
interesting
well then let me actually go back to
this post here because aha
maya sees arya as her inspiration to
stay strong in tough times good that's
good that's good okay that's good to
know good to know good to know all right
so there's some drama between her and
baby doll but it doesn't say anything
about that
this rex is like perfect in every way
there is nothing
rex has never done a goddamn thing wrong
in rex's life rex grabs life by the
throat and you can too if you use my
link in the description to follow my
patented deep throating technology you
too can be like rex and you can make
millions of dollars every minute every
minute
okay rex is validation despite his
dubious side business rex is still
recognized by legitimate organizations
like bizcon and gets invited to speak
there
that's because he's never done a wrong
thing in his life he's a legitimate
trabillionaire
he has so much money i'm surprised
there's no evidence about this because
this
is pretty damning
grab success by the throat
all right nothing else here let me look
at my
my doobie dabbers
mean his image erica's full name do i
have erica's full name
eric uh
erica here's something about erica
apparently that was it okay a discussion
with mina regarding her involvement in
the road accident that led to erica's
death
police report
ah i see
ah it was my suggestion to use erica as
an inspiration to drum up support okay
you've got more talent in your little
pinky than most of the trash museums
museums musicians
okay interesting interesting so there's
gotta be
oh god
you know for someone who's such a tragic
rock star i don't buy any of mina's
mellow drama there's no record of any of
her stories
see if she mentions any specific
incident
something you can look up on the police
database
it covers everything from murder to
accidents i know it's literally what i'm
doing get over yourself get over
yourself okay so erica what is erica's
full
name erica was there something on
chimera about no you're arya
mina erica
not this one
this one
where was it where was it where was it
if there's some kind of database here
for accidents
district okay i need
i need district all this stuff okay so
what is the song right first of august
ah erica simmons
okay august in what district this is
here
my birthday week has always been
really hard for me okay i wrote my
friend died in
albuquerque
[Music]
in albuquerque oh
[Music]
used to think we will live forever
let all our dreams
[Music]
used to feel you will always be by my
side you went to show me
was denied in nevada
[Music]
in
new york
and now that you are gone
[Music]
in
tennessee town
[Music]
in all of the florida bars i don't know
where
yeah but where where are your scars what
district are your scars in all right
fine
[Music]
district i don't know what the district
would be but i know it's august right so
it's august
if i just get erica simmons in here
maybe you would find something
[Music]
oh
no
that's a good scan wrecks of fraud it
affected many people and they all want
justice
sure
[Music]
hmm interesting
meanness tragic stories may be made up
or exaggerated but they've genuinely
helped others come to terms with their
own grief and suffering that's nice
asking for likes quick to take the easy
way out of her problems like asking for
likes from her fans to boost her
dwindling popularity
what is the district
oh here we go
i need someone's contact i just dm'd you
i'll trade you for some exclusive news
anything you want save the big
influencer contact leaks before you got
deleted me who knows i might be in a
sharing mood interesting
okay
let me just um let me get these in here
ambassador
maya i'm beyond annoyed such an
inconvenience look at this can you
believe this bowl due to the sheer
volume of applications blah blah blah
blah how hard do i have to try oh like
why can't i just get it i'm clearly
perfect for this if only i had a friend
who could help me out a friend with
connections to allurin a friend who
slays it fitness and curating diet plans
a friend that i dearly respect and
appreciate a friend i'm forwarding this
email to
but seriously if you know anyone on the
inside please let me know okay bye
okay bye
i guess i know whoa
hi
let's do it baby rex's new recruits
email address
okay what about wasn't there something
in the email with um
rags here we go
no
wham let me in baby i'm claiming my spot
no
[ __ ]
okay new recruits wait
did i not see someone right here
i somehow almost missed this
aha pumped up clicks alrighty then that
is the last piece of information that i
need
bam
open
my my someone suddenly has grown
unconscious touching he can make his own
decisions it's not my fault he's such a
puppy dog i didn't force him to quit
just a few choice words on how working
for me could be pretty good for him
that's all don't worry you're pretty
little head about anything plus assume
his enthusiasm is good for my operation
him being all excited in his face in the
program is gonna get more people to join
they love that genuine entity
crap you're right about one thing though
he could be better at use at the gym
maybe i'll let him stay there thanks my
ola me and a whole lot of people oh you
won rex king
all right well did that actually answer
any questions for me i really don't even
know
anyway dr murillo
look we're running out of time here so
we got to wrap this up fast
arya looks like a nice enough girl but
my gut tells me she's got a lot more
insecurities than she's letting on from
experience someone like that is going to
do whatever they can for validation even
if they have to fake it
i think you should push her buttons on
this see if she's really as genuinely
confident as she seems yeah right now my
suspicion is with arya
because i know rex seems like the
obvious choice but i think it is just a
red herring he blows a lot of hot air
about being an entrepreneur but the only
business he's ever registered is his
motivational company where he's the only
employee right i dug up some posts
online saying he's running some sort of
scam
find out more about this i will
i will this warden app is really
something
i'm glad i'm damn glad the departments
spend money on this elise how's it
working out for you no problem restoring
files this software is amazing
really is isn't it
imagine unraveling a potential suspect's
lives through their phones moment by
moment every single thing exposed
nothing stays hidden all of that porn so
much porn what a wonderful time to be in
law enforcement
because of the porn sounds like you
really enjoy spying on people
i'm not doing this for personal
gratification
this is about getting justice and if i
have to go through miles and miles of
porn to get to justice you're goddamn
right i will i have the right to do
whatever necessary to get my job done no
matter the porn i have to pour through
and now's not the time for trivial
debates there's far too much porn to
to analyze to get to the bottom of this
we have to get back to the porn i don't
see anything strange again not that i
ever did in the first place
anyway i'm all out of time for this
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching
so
bye
[Music]
you